mais c'est un système assez complexe
déjà actif avec beaucoup de nuages qui
apportent des orages et ce système est
prévu se rapprocher de l'arc antillais
et lors de son déplacement il va
s'activer et se creuser pour former une
dépression tropicale
peut-être une tempête tropicale donc au
moment où il va arriver sur l'arc
antillais en particulier sur le nord de
l'arc antillais
il va apporter du mauvais temps et ça
c'est attendu pour mercredi prochain
alors il n'est pas prévu que ce système
on se creuse de façon
très importante donc ça veut dire qu'on
va pas avoir des vents extrêmement fort
méfiance comme mais malgré tout on va
avoir des vents qui sort de l'ordinaire
on va avoir des vents avec des vitesses
moyennes de l'ordre de 50 km/heure
peut-être 60 kilomètres heure les
rafales de l'ordre de 60 70 km/heure
davantage sur les hauteurs sur les morts
dont on pourrait atteindre les 80 90 km
à revoit très ponctuellement 100
km/heure associé également à 7 à ce
phénomène des puits et des plus
importantes qui vont démarrer dès la
nuit de mardi à mercredi qui pourrait
durer relativement longtemps jusqu'à la
journée de jeudi incluse et au passage
donc de ces masses nuageuses pluvieuse
on peut avoir des quantités très
importantes de l'ordre de 100 à 150 mm
localement peut-être davantage en
pression on affinera un petit peu les
valeurs au fur et à mesure qu'on aura
des éléments supplémentaires
et ça c'est un élément très important à
retenir
et puis associé également donc au vent
au vent relativement fort on va avoir
une mère également qui va se creuser
on atteint des hauteurs d'eau on attend
des hauteurs de vagues de l'ordre de 2
mètres 50 à 3 m dans les canaux en
atlantique également attention également
sur une mer un petit peu atypique en mer
caraïbe où on va avoir peut-être des
creux de l'ordre de un mètre avec des
vents qui serait exposé temporairement à
l'ouest et ensuite qu'ils vont
s'orienter au sud donc des ventes porter
vers le rivage
de la côte sous le vent donc voilà un
comportement un petit peu atypique des
conditions des conditions
météorologiques